[Music]
yesterday at the North American leaders
summit in Ottawa Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau shared a very awkward
handshake with President Obama and
Mexican president Enrique Nieto and yeah
kind of strange moment take a look there
you see him right in the middle Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau kind of a lynx
ham and then this is cross over what was
that about Margaret and were people
buzzing about that awkward moment yeah
if people keep talking about it was very
awkward now
that's the clip that was shown to the
public okay but yeah they I guess edit
it down to make it look less awkward
that was the less awkward version
actually there was much more to that
handshake we tracked down the raw
footage before it was edited take a look
Rio mugo summit the three big neighbors
here and Justin Trudeau putting himself
in the center of that photograph as host
kind of couldn't figure out which
direction to go in first whose hands
because he was tried to first embrace
everyone all at once yeah someone said I
look like President Obama was he
[Applause]
yay yay we figured out how to get a
pirate in there that's the important
thing
you